let's start tonight by appreciating the
heroes of this crisis of course the
nurses and doctors risking their own
health to protect ours but also the
hospital cleaners and the truck drivers
and shelf stack as they are the ones
literally keeping America going and it
was another week of strong action by the
president in the war against coronavirus
just today as we saw announcing the
extension of the slow the spread
guidelines until April the 30th putting
together the biggest and quickest rescue
plan for workers families and small
businesses in American history cutting
red tape and getting a 15-minute
coronavirus test FDA approved deploying
FEMA and the Army Corps of Engineers to
build a hospital in New York in a week
with many more to come around the
country invoking the defense production
act to get the ventilators our hospitals
need an appointing Peter Navarro as
coordinator Americans are rallying
behind this leadership which of course
the media hate so we get headlines like
this stunning poll finds 60% of
Americans approve of Trump's coronavirus
response it's only stunning if you see
everything even this national emergency
through the sick distorted lens of
anti-trump mania he was the same with
the president's leadership this week on
ending the total shutdown of our economy
as we put it last Sunday flattened the
curve not the economy here's the
president America will again and soon be
open for business very soon a lot sooner
than three or four months if somebody
was suggesting lot sooner we cannot let
the Cure be worse than the problem
itself you'd think he'd announced a
policy of mass murder Donald Trump
actually said today that if you do not
go back to work by Easter you will kill
yourselves that's what he said that's
the way Donald Trump actually sees this
situation that's the way Donald Trump
sees you Donald Trump does not believe
that life is worth living if you lose
money that is so disgusting
these people are consumed by hatred of
Trump in any case the
resident didn't say go back to work by
Easter he said he wants to see the
country back to work as soon as possible
and that if he's to were possible that
would be great but in the exact same
interview he said he would review it
with his task force which he has then
they announced the outcome today not
Easter but April the 30th two and a half
weeks later the way the Trump haters
talked the president wanting to open up
America as quickly as possible makes him
some kind of monster but you didn't hear
a peep out of them when New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo said the same
thing when New York Times columnist Tom
Friedman the great guru of the global
elite and rabid never trumpet Bret
Stevens said the same thing when an
actual public health expert Yale
preventative health professor David Katz
said the same thing or when an actual
public health official the medical
director of Maricopa County Arizona said
the same thing I've never seen such
support for anything we've said on this
show as for our message last week
flattened a curve not the economy both
parts of that are vital flatten the
curve so our hospitals aren't
overwhelmed but don't flatten American
workers and Families in the process the
president understands this because he
knows who's hurt by the total shutdown
not the TV Talking Heads and blue
checked Twitter chirp is working in the
knowledge economy but the real
blue-collar working-class construction
workers factory workers restaurant
workers retail workers and the families
who rely on them and the cost of a
prolonged shutdown is not just about
their jobs but their lives in fact it
will literally take years off their
lives poverty can take up to 10 years of
someone's life in America between 2008
and 2010 every 1% increase in the
unemployment rate was accompanied by a
roughly 1 percent increase in the
suicide rate with last week's
devastating numbers the unemployment
rate has already nearly doubled to 5.5
percent if we carry on with this total
shutdown some predict we'll see
unemployment rise to 30%
you think this is all just abstract
statistics listen to the mayor the
sheriff of Knox County Tennessee this
week over the past 48 hours that office
has now examined nine suspected suicides
eight of which are from Knox County
alone four Knox County that's almost 10
percent of last year's total number in
the past two days alone that number is
utterly shocking and makes me wonder is
what we are doing now really the best
approach how can we respond to Coba 19
in a way that keeps our economy intact
keeps people employed and empowers our
people with the feeling of hope and
optimism not desperation and despair
it's not just the corona virus that
kills people poverty kills despair kills
if this total shot down goes on too long
it will kill more people than
coronavirus you just won't see the
numbers in a neat little box on cable
news I'm so sick of irresponsible idiots
on TV pretending this is all so simple
save every life well if you really want
to save every life then take seriously
the death rate from the total shutdown
acknowledge the pain and suffering of
millions of struggling Americans for
whom the people on TV seem to show no
understanding or empathy flatten the
curve not the economy obviously doesn't
mean pretend the virus doesn't exist and
lift all restrictions overnight no one's
saying ignore public health we're saying
that the virus and the shot down both
hurt public health so we need to balance
the two and here's how it's a simple
message open where possible closed where
necessary we now have a month more to
slow the spread let's make it count
but as we do let's push the public
health officials to develop a plan that
is more targeted and surgical than a
total shutdown
we have the data to identify the people
most at risk of needing hospital
treatment protect them if you're older
with a serious underlying health
condition
should stay home compulsory quarantine
protect vulnerable places an all-out
effort to help New York City New Orleans
and emerging hotspots with the equipment
and resources they need but also protect
the places that are relatively
unaffected so they can open up a rural
Idaho County became a hot spot because
of wealthy visitors fleeing places like
New York and Seattle that is not okay
quite rightly the White House has now
implemented a travel advisory to stop
that kind of spread and I hope we see
more even during the next month and
certainly afterwards the right strategy
to reduce the coronavirus death rate and
the shot down death rate is open where
possible closed where necessary
that would mean keeping the ban on large
gatherings but it could also mean for
example opening up workplaces just with
temperature checks for all workers by
the way this is completely in line with
what the doctor Falchi has said you find
after a period of time that there are
areas that are very different from other
areas of the country you may not want to
essentially treat it as it just one
force for the entire country
but look like flexibility in different
areas flexibility in different areas
open where possible closed where
necessary to enable that flexibility
will need to continue the rapid progress
in testing so we can decide place by
place where it's possible to open up and
where it's necessary to stay closed but
the vital thing the president did last
week was to change the conversation from
the despair of indefinite shutdown to
the hope of careful reopening he put a
light at the end of the tunnel so in
this extra month of shot-down
let's commit to a new phase in this
fight more targeted more surgical more
balanced open where possible closed
where necessary that's the way to
flatten the curve without flattening the
economy